welcome to this video part 8 of the
pre-war championship series presenting
memorable games by the two players this
is carlton video and i have a little
story about each of books games probably
this was played term in the german
bundesliga the first leaked in germany
played in 2006 if i'm not mistaken i
have it the other screen was it 2007
let's let me check 2007 actually and my
little story is that in 2005 and Magnus
was just breaking through 15 years old
um I tried to try to get him to play for
my team in in rule on being back then
just had promoted to the first league
and actually had a couple of males um
I'm a male exchange with his father
Henry Carlton and we offered him to play
first board which at the time was a very
interesting offer because he obviously
was very talented and so on but still
the first born in the Bundesliga is very
strong and yeah we had some some some
nice some mail exchange but it
ultimately didn't didn't work out and
simply a schedule even back then was too
too crowded to to make any commitment to
a leak however I wanted two years later
Carson actually joined a team in the
Bundesliga and he plays for baden-baden
he still probably is on the list but he
never plays basically simply not enough
time with all the tournaments all right
so let's see this is a play 2007 and his
opponent is um Grandmaster a check from
hmm yeah I'm terribly sorry i had a
should have looked it up before i see
from the czech republic are from
slovakia i think from the
republic okay let's see what happens
among is playing d4 and we get a Queens
gambit in fact the main point of this
game the main phase of this game is the
end game so I don't want to spend lots
of time on the opening or the middle
game we get the tactical go variation or
Talackova mark are gonna bundle risky I
think this is how the Russians call it
this is one of the most solid defenses
to the Queens gambit and very good
choice for black it's some good balance
between solid play and still keeping a
bit of action going and what has many
many options this is one of them there
should be three developing and here
black young usually goes 94 on night bd7
but in this game where check took on c4
and played 90 for this is a simplifying
line that is quite similar in nature to
the to the last guy variation of the
Queens gambit declined lucky strangers
pieces to relieve some pressure his
ideas of course to go see 5 and then try
to equalize completely in fact in this
game and like it got very close to
equality so yeah the song quite quite
natural and now see 5 black managed to
get in this move and also managed to get
this Bishop into play which is the main
feature of course of the tar take over
that this problem Bishop gets to live so
white only has a very minuscule
advantage in this position should be to
d5 and here maybe black could have
considered to drop all the way back
maybe better
this son now is a bit better for white I
just mention it's not not the main point
of this game to go into the middle game
quickly this is a weak point but black
has pressure with the bishop is trying
to get activity with the Queen in fact
he gets the a porn so white only retains
a slide initiative based on this active
night the night also covering you for so
it is it is a slide pool but it's
nothing spectacular like activating the
rook and we get at this position here in
fact like it could have played f5 but
this is very difficult for a human to
spot taking a success the idea so quite
strange the idea is that this is working
threatening this and so f5 would have
been interesting I mean it's not not
willing for black or anything it's
probably probably equal because it
activates the night if we look at what
the best movers white can can do
something like that and this is a draw
probably Queens Roxy to is a funny idea
check but if you want to look at this
you you can but I want to focus on the
endgame rope d4 Knight c3 and we get
further exchanges yeah
has this bishop and it's it's biting on
granite this is the main problem and
this is a week or so it's very young and
comfortable to play yeah of course night
2d6 not I'm not capturing here allowing
allowing this this is nothing what needs
to keep the pressure on and this is what
Magnus is especially great at always
setting little blue problem so this was
too quick wanted to what to do to
comment that yeah what what is blacks
problem here is his just completely tied
down to this weakness and here black has
a choice he can stay put and try to do
nothing trying to defend passively or
you can give up a pond and try your luck
in the rook endgame and this is what he
does it's a probably the best choice he
plays Bishop to be seven this gives up
pawn but it gets rid of this bad bishop
for the price of this beep on however
the rook is in front of the pawn so this
is considerably more difficult task then
oops enacted is wrong if the look would
be on b1 wet supports the the beep on
from behind the old tower rule but in
front of it it's just much more much
more of a problem still this end game
probably should end in a draw with the
precise play but we see that there are
many ideas and the fact that we get to
some very instructive position so this
is why I ever chooses um yup like now
can give this check which is perfectly
all right okay again this check and why
term which reads
in this position black cam has a choice
and he he didn't go for quite the magic
move it's always difficult to to assess
12 to assess what kind of traits you
should go for in the same game what I'm
talking about is here black could have
played h5 which in fact is a very
typical move in the serm structure a try
very often is good because it prevents
white from advancing g4 and gaining
further space on the on the King side
and the problem here is that you give up
f77 but you get B 2 in return and this
was an alternative um and probably
probably black should hold this in the
long run with perfect play this is it
there then the problem is white is still
better and can try for ages but this was
an interesting idea not not necessarily
better than the game but it was was an
option and King g6 and now very
important g4 this is a move that you
should take note of it gains space it
prevents like from playing a try for
instance and it allows further ideas
like advancing with the king of it it
supports in the long run this this push
here so this is very typical to make any
progress the problem is that this rook
is obviously very active on the second
rank and how do you ever activate the
king and this is one possibility to to
go to go in this way the other problem
is that the porn itself does not promote
and we will see what happens King f6
before you need to advance it a bit you
cannot do without to de-spawn being
involved in
so yes giving a couple of checks this is
okay and Carlton steps up to g3 this is
just trying to keep the position as it
is an alternative and interesting
alternative was King III setting yeah
setting up for for this journey to the
beep on this term is very interesting
maybe it's winning but it's it's hard to
figure out we can have have a look at a
sample line rook takes g2 and what
should why do now probably continue to
march with the king can you form j5
check King c5 and what should like do
now probably checking from the from from
behind is the best check Chingy 6 okay
like continues to check check until the
King runs out of out of squares I mean
runs all the squares is some some
probably the wrong expression until it
decides to to do any any sort of
progress and designs to go go here
otherwise you are not going anywhere and
this is the point where black needs to
initiate further counter play like this
getting here so that the end you can
march up your own pawns this is always
the problem with those end games at the
end um you get the race situation where
this pawn probably promotes but at the
same time black also get spawns rolling
and sometimes you have rook against one
or two points at the end which is
sometimes hard to assess so on let's
continue a bit here whoopsie seven
cupcakes
three and we'll see five clearing the
way for the King to see seven and then
the pawn can be can be advanced gingy
five and now let's have a look at this
King c7 kingi 4b six of course you
cannot calculate this I'm just trying to
to show her the typical way this this
game might progress seven and now they
each poem is starting to run and
probably this should end in a draw but
it's it's very tricky and we are talking
about a very long variation here it's
very difficult to assess and sometimes
if you miss calculator those pots can
get really dangerous so I also decided
to not do that yet and play clean g3
just keeping the position as is and
maybe going for that at a later stage
now e5 is played some probably the right
move and b6 you cannot do without the
bleep on g6 probably right this is
flexible it allows h5 @ at the
appropriate moment will be 8 often
useful because you sometimes need p7 for
the king if you go all the way round
this is the square where you often put
your king then the rook and group CA
drugs is six kings e7 and then March the
bond ok King g7 King edge to it's not
much happening but we get to the
critical point soon enough in fact you
could analyze this in much more detail
but I don't want to do an hour long
video in this series it's a
more focused on presenting some some
points per game um okay and this is the
critical position where black now is is
making the decisive mistake interesting
interestingly enough the best way to
play seems to be just checking check
here and I'll see white how you're going
to make any progress it seems that
compared to the line before King III
here is some it's less dangerous even
because black gets a very quick h5 in so
let's say like this King be three let me
check my notes here oops this is a
jungle of variations qb3 King III is it
yeah probably from the h5 not age five
let me check check it's this is of
course data I'm sorry okay white is
quicker that way we have to look at this
line this is much better I just got to
the wrong row here in this as mentioned
jungle of jungle of lines and yeah King
see form using using the king and then
h5 takes takes and it's a difficult
stuff for the computer to evaluate this
probably it it is a draw but the
computer needs quite some time to
calculate deep enough to to recognize
the draw black game gets this active
play with the edge porn so on we can we
can continue this look h8 oakley to King
c5 I guess
kinsey five and then King g5 supporting
the pawn and that it is a drama just by
hack okay white white can only get get
get to make any progress here if he goes
to the bee farm so here then aged four
and it is some a ch-47 know bb7 and now
black gets to gets to those pawns let's
say something changes and then this is
not enough if the King Lewis you get you
get further checks so something like
this check and it's it simply not enough
but it is very close I'm only presenting
a abbreviated version here of the
analysis so this is what black should
have done but the main point is what
what happens after what you played
kingly six which looks completely
innocuous why should should this be bad
but in fact them it now gets very very
tricky and due to the interesting move
b7 this happiness in fact quite often
mistake of this kind of news putting
your pawn on the same drink is in fact
quite often a mistake in this type of
endgame where you have the look in front
of the porn simply because you often
need this be seven square for the king
at the end of all this then advantage of
however of having the pawn here is sort
of a technical nature or not let's say
it's it's it's something very concrete
you always threaten this check in and
promote so blacks choice is very limited
here in this position
um as to go to f6 to avoid the checks
and now we see that white can make
further progress interestingly enough by
means of playing g3 intending f4 and one
important point of having the pawn on b7
is of course whenever black leaves the B
file like here here then thus or simply
the rook moving and it promotes so black
it's very much limited the rook is tied
to the B file cannot really go anywhere
else I mean if it gives a check okay but
other than that it would allow the white
look to move and promote you cannot move
the king okay you could go to the seven
but it cannot go here and you're very
limited with your further movement cm if
for instance we we can look at this he
now played the now played the move g52
to block here but very interesting and
instructive continuation and since after
h5 and this is something that you really
should remember and this is f form this
is a very typical way to play and it
means led at the end if you have this
type of configuration the look in front
of the pawn wear this look on b2 is tied
to it it always is a matter of zeus one
like cannot go here cannot go here and
what should you do we probably shouldn't
take at some point and now the problem
is that those pawns are simply marching
and black young cannot really do
anything to prevent and a further
passport to to emerge let's say just for
instance King g75 King h7 black has has
nothing better then at the end you
it to this oh this is also ok can it's
the f porn at the point and at the end
white is winning due to this trick check
this means that you can always win if
you have the rook in front of the pot
and you get an F pawn as an additional
passer and this is very important to
know those kind of ideas because then at
this position you can simply stop
calculating because you know it's
winning you don't need to figure out
anything concrete yeah it's it's just a
win and pretty pretty easy one in
comparison also there are all kinds of
phone okay this is very easy sorry just
Rock g8 but if you look at this there
are all kinds of breakthroughs that's
just for it since King f6 g5 King f-5e 6
yeah it's all it's a tactical thing
based on this configuration this is
check a win on King takes also win note
that the king is nicely positioned to
this king it's nicely positioned to deal
with the passive cm so you always have
those yeah let's say breakthrough ideas
d 5 is however instead of f5 this is the
easier way to go so always keep in mind
the be porn and it's the same with the C
porn from if you can if you combine this
with the F porn it's a straight win so
this means that black cannot play h5m
his choice is really limited if he goes
to to g7 for example then we get this
King March is very similar to the to the
game another good move is f form also
should win
he played g5 however and now the King
starts to dance to approach blackest as
mentioned completely tied he cannot move
the rook away from the beef are so chant
gives a couple of checks check until he
needs to stay put here anyway and like
he move doesn't have it all so White's
King now advances check check check
there was wasn't anything better simply
King us on them on yet and he now played
into g7 he has an interesting line rugby
to king of 8 p-3 Luke c8 and now we have
a very nice paid threat Black has has no
way to prevent queening and technique
preventing the server cube mate ok king
yet what what did happen they played
King g7 to prevent King Ovid King e7
rugby to King g6 now attacking this pawn
and yeah what about f6 yeah this is
again a position to remember how does
why to make progress here in this way
gives up the pawn check to get to this
king opponent game and yeah but how do
you actually win it let's let's check in
g6 how do you make any progress here of
course by going here and now black is in
suits long he needs to play h5 no no
other moves
this just gives away every porn so h5
check takes and King to g7 and like has
no way to to keep the pause for example
after GE form okay you're just too quick
so black needs to go to f6 again to to
cover the pawn what about Group B 5 I
don't have it in my notes I wouldn't
okay of course you win a temple and rook
moves and then you just just clear the
way okay this is not working so it needs
to go King f6 and now we have a very
neat finish and this is rather rather
typical good therefore Y term starts
with this breakthrough what should like
to where he doesn't really have much
choice here I needs to take it takes
this is what he played he confronts
taking it she took with the pawn it
leads to the same thing and now he took
on their form not much choice as
mentioned and now we get the the point
of all this while is playing rook g8 and
now if what happens if black takes
technique the cute mate very often made
is a very very key point in end games
like it's a very economical I really
like it this is Lucas taking away those
squares f5 is taken by by dude by the
porn and then if I that's just just a
straight made so black has no
alternative he needs to allow King and
now what about the f porn is there some
counter play now almost
look at this move it threatens King d 6
and e5 made so black cannot check Nate
promote after King b6 is already
unstoppable so black must play there's
just this move because King g6 was such
a huge threat and now it's easy rookie a
check care for and King d5 if now black
tries to promote you just have work
evade and check I when the Queen the to
resign no still played f6 and now we
resigned if no way to to promote the
f-bomb so this was a very interesting
and instructive endgame I only scratched
the surface with analysis here because I
didn't really intend to make an hour
long video what what should you try to
remember from this game one very
important thing is which really should
net many points the rook endgames is
this idea that an f porn together with
such configurations like on the beef I
look in front of the pawn is winning by
itself you don't even need the King to
to support action here this is important
and also note this nice combination of
checkmating check check check no church
axiom this mating ideas is very nice
also keep in mind this idea that the
rook this book trade going to a key and
porn end game is very often winning if
you enjoy such huge space advantage it
needs to be calculated of course but
very often this is a winning idea where
you trade down into this earth is
winning king of gone endgame yeah it was
not a particularly
exciting game or something spectacular
but it showed there are some very nice
points in the rookie and game I hope you
enjoyed it it's a it's rather typical
game of cards is very precise and end
games alright thanks for watching